Carson meanwhile smiling because he
knows he's he's tricked dubov he's
surprised him he just tricked
oh why is Magnus Carlson having a huge
laugh here David uh I mean unless he's
listening to us I'm not sure K remember
he laughed the other day and we asked
him and he couldn't remember why he was
laughing well this is a bigger laugh a
few moments later he doesn't want to
trade off Rooks he doesn't want to trade
off Queens wow killer move there I think
Magnus Carson just blundered his Queen
Magnus Carson blunders his Queen Daniel
dubov about to win will Magnus resign if
Pawn takes Rook there's Checkmate if
Rook takes Rook White Queen disappears
Magnus Carlson he's about to resign look
at him cursing to himself checkmating
the the world champion again just like
in the a things
Masters okay he's shouting loudly um he
has resigned Magnus Carlson losing game
two with the white pieces against denal
dubov